you know you have to snap so as you can
like slowly start to heal I came to kill
so see your queen got that first bz how
did you prepare for the ending kind of
horribly actually I was like so in
denial and I was like one of the last
people to wrap which isn't a spoiler the
last person it was our last day here the
most seen last and um yeah it was just
like really putting it off because I've
watched so many people wrap and cry and
I was like I had to like stay out of
that emotion because I've so much to do
and like some really difficult units to
do and then I wrapped and I like I was
emotional but like I really did feel
numb that's when my numbers came and
then it wasn't till like a week later
that I was like you know amy was doing
something and like you drop a spoon like
overreacting entirely and I just felt
like an insane person thing you did that
for it yeah I just like to you know you
have to snap so as you can like slowly
start to heal what's worst of westeros I
don't know no one knows
it's where all the maps top
that's where I'm going